assalamualaikum greens of Peace how you
guys doing subscribe if you haven't
already hit that notification Bell now
I'm going to share a few videos that
will share with me I'm going to share
them with you because I think this is
very important that we're up to speed
we're up to date on what's going on
first one is they're all with women
so inshallah this gets the women
feminists really motivated to step up
and defend these women's rights because
this is a matter of women's rights this
is this is clear violation and
oppression on women on children so let's
get into this first video
of a woman going into the YMCA she
thinks she's going to a safe environment
there to go ahead into the woman's
supposed to be the woman's locker room
lo and behold she is surprised by what
happens next and this is her testimony
her story check it out my name is
Rebecca Phillips and I'm 17 years old I
am not a resident of Santee but I am
employed at a local restaurant The
Omelette Factory and I work out
regularly at the Santee YMCA
just two weeks ago after finishing my
shift at my job I went to the gym just
when laps as I was showering after my
workout I saw a naked male in the
women's locker room
I immediately went back into the shower
terrified and hid behind their flimsy
excuse for a curtain until he was gone
I ran into a bathroom stall to change as
quickly as I could organizing my
thoughts to share with the people at the
front desk
as I did so I could only think of my
five-year-old sister who I bring to this
gym during the summer
sorry to enjoy their water slides
this is the YMCA
where hundreds of children spend their
summer afternoons in child care camps
this is the YMCA where my little sister
took gymnastics lessons
the locker room was supposed to be her
safe haven to gossip with her friends
and shower and change
when I asked to YMCA management what
their policy was regarding transgenders
they confirmed that the man that I saw
was indeed allowed to shower wherever he
pleased as long as you are not a red
flag on Megan's Law
the California sex offender registry a
grown male can shower alongside a
teenage girl at your YMCA location here
in Santee
I was made to feel as though I had done
something wrong when I talked to people
at the YMCA
somehow the indecent exposure of a male
to a female minor was an inconvenience
to them
when my dad spoke to the Sheriff's
Office they told him that he should
never allow me to shower there ever
again
the YMCA wouldn't let my father speak to
the manager of the Santee Branch after
waiting several days he finally received
a call from Terry Moss who is the
director of membership for San Diego
County
she informed my dad that I was not in
any danger at the time of the incident
that I was safe
but I ask you this I'm assuming all of
you either have a wife a sister
daughters or granddaughters or or a
woman yourself
could you knowingly send an underage
girl into a room where there was a naked
male and say that she was not in danger
that she was safe
or more importantly that this was right
the fact that we are now tailoring our
privacy policies and bathroom laws
around transgenders ignoring the blatant
threat to safety that this poses is
obscene
the safety of children Girls is on The
Chopping Block
and this issue is not unique to one
political party both Democrats and
Republicans who might have shared the
story with have all been equally
disgusted
so I implore you all to take action
with great privilege comes great
responsibility
whether it's requiring transgenders to
use the Single Cell family restrooms or
making them use the bathroom which
aligns with their biological trans
state your name and where you live for
the record
on the wall in detail
in an effort by the city and the YMCA to
apply the neocultural gender rules at
Mountain View pool dressing shower room
facilities women and children are being
put at risk
my experience while showering after my
swim was hearing a man's voice in the
women's dressing area and seeing a man
in a women's swimsuit watching little
girls pull down their bathing suits in
order to use the toilets in the dressing
room
I reacted by telling him to leave and
the consequence is that I have been
banned from the pool
there is no signage informing women the
shower room is now all gender and what
that means nor have parents been
informed of what they can expect with
these news policies
the Y has not provided any dressing
shower room options for women who do not
want to be exposed to men who identify
as women
it is unconscionable that the YMCA would
instigate these new policies without
clearly informing pool patrons and
parents
although in 2021 the Y reported that
they were adding family and all gender
dressing and bathing areas they've not
done that
instead they've usurped the binary
designations and turned the facilities
into all gender with no choices
the staff seems to have received little
professional training on how to handle
reactions to such a radical cultural
change particularly for the most
vulnerable older female patrons and
children who may be exposed to
inappropriate behavior the dignity and
safety of unsuspecting women who have
trusted to use these facilities for many
years this is not right
the YMCA the city the police and
sheriffs the parents need to come
together to figure out how to make the
new policies work for all pool patrons
not just one group
how to keep children who are less able
to discriminate safe
it is ironic that women who discriminate
when a situation threatens their safety
or their children a message from our
ancestors
are now accused of discrimination as if
they have made someone else a victim
we need to do much more intelligence and
wise about applying the rules and
developing policies that are respectful
and inclusive
thank you thank you thank you
okay next video something very similar
in these things as you can see they're
just popping up this is happening uh
imagine how many are just not being
filmed like this so now you you got to
be aware of tomorrow you're sending your
wife or you're sending your family your
daughter and you think you're sending
her into the bathroom or you're thinking
you're sending her into all women's
locker room you got to be aware that
these are the kind of things now that
could that can happen so we want to keep
our children safe want to keep our
families safe so you can't be naive to
the new what they want to push the new
Norm so this is the second video same
thing woman
in a locker room and she gets surprise
with this
girls under age your spa we Spa condone
that is that what you're saying
like I asked it's so he can stay there
he could stay there okay no I'm not one
actually I'm a woman who knows how to
stand up and speak up from my right as a
woman I have a right to feel comfortable
without a man exposing himself okay no
you go somewhere else okay so that's
right no he's not a transgender he has a
penis just like you do are you are you
are you are you I understand no yeah
okay it's not okay it's not okay okay
that's traumatizing to see that I'm a
woman I think this is a place right here
I'm cold only for women so how dare you
sit up here and tell me I don't have a
right as a woman
I'm telling you he has a penis a full in
testicle okay and I don't care what it's
called it's a man you got one you're a
man a men's section with art Anatomy
that would be well it wouldn't probably
but you might not like women so it might
not no we don't know but for me and for
a lot of other women they do not feel
comfortable and it's not okay
okay all right moving along we got one
final one same scenario you can see a
pattern here so This Woman's at the gym
and she gets surprised with a man coming
into the ladies was supposed to be the
Ladies Room the ladies washroom the
ladies changing room and this is her
encounter and her experience
uh what happened to her here are the
facts surrounding Paul Bixler he's a 72
year old biological man for the most of
his life he has been married has two
children he has lived the life of a
biological man he is attracted to women
he was married to a woman
30 40 years he sits on the school board
of an elementary school in Buckeye
Arizona called Liberty Elementary this
man is claiming to be a woman it's a bad
picture hold on there we go this man
tells the little children at the school
that he is a woman he wears clothing he
wears lipstick and he uses the same
restroom the same restroom as your
little girls
he also uses the women's locker room at
esport of Fitness in Goodyear Arizona he
has been spotted yesterday in the
women's locker room in esport of Fitness
in Goodyear Arizona
he went on local television claiming
victimhood because people like myself
parents who have the right to speak up
against their elected officials are
harassing and bullying him
Paul Bixler cannot be voted off the
school board he must either willingly
step down or be recalled the recall is
being started please email Paul Bixler
his email is in the description let him
know kindly that he stepped down from
the school board willingly and cease and
desist from using women's facilities or
charges will be filed with the Buckeye
Police Department
I am at the gym in Arizona
who's undressing in the locker room top
off
and a Pug mixer was in the women's
locker room and he looked at me and he
looked at my breasts
and I have called the police
so
that he's
I have told the police that I was in the
locker room a man was in there I was
getting undressed he looked at me he is
a man in the women's locker room
and the response is that this is a
touchy sensitive issue in society
there's no one undressing in there
there's no naked women in there since
there's a man why isn't anyone warning
the women
just so everyone knows he's not being
arrested we are at a point where we're
catering to society instead of facts
is alarming women's rights are being
violated
and I'm not going to put up with it
you're a female why do you use the men's
restroom sometimes and the women's
restroom sometimes
please stay away
yes politely like I said he will suffer
no now you guys uh you know as Muslims
we're very protective over our family we
are ones who is very explicitly lucidly
clear in the verbatim word of God
Almighty the Quran there's true certain
truths in there they they cannot be
compromised like for instance the pure
monotheism is very clear in there that
God Almighty Allah is only one there's
only one God cannot be three and one one
three it's very clear the Quran is very
very clear on the day of judgment that
the day of judgment is coming the Quran
is very clear about Paradise the Quran
is very clear about the Hellfire uh the
Quran paints a very very Vivid and clear
picture of the people who transgress and
people who are oppressors and unjust and
all of these things you know the people
who sped evil and corruption in the land
this is very clear of what awaits them
so there are certain
truths the purpose of life very clear in
the Quran what you've been created for
what's your purpose in life very clear
in the Quran and another one related to
this topic
very explicitly clear that the man is
not like the woman the woman is not like
the man God Almighty has created the man
and created the woman and he is the only
one without a gender so it's very very
lucidly clear that we cannot compromise
when it comes to these things because
this is part of our religion our Dean
our way of life now watching all this
and just seeing the progression of the
catering to people's desires to catering
to people to go ahead and transgress on
other people's rights
it reminded me of a verse and Ayah from
the vermato verbatim word of God
Almighty the Quran in chapter 23 verse
71 this is the creator speaking this is
the meaning where he says but if the
truth had followed their desires their
inclinations the heavens and the Earth
and whatever
is in them would have been ruined so you
see what happens you can see the
progression slowly and slowly what's
happening when the human being is let to
follow his or her desires and what kind
of transgressions are
being transgressed so we have to stand
guard to protect our families to protect
our loved ones
and we can't be naive to what's going on
we need to speak up we need to
collaborate with other people uh people
of the book Jews Christians and people
over the face also who see this as a
violation of Rights who want to protect
their women folk and they want to
protect their children
this is something where we need to work
together we need to be a voice we need
to show that this is wrong this is not
the way forward and we need to stand up
and speak out we need to speak out we
cannot remain silent hopefully this
motivates more people to speak out
and we'll see you next time until then
peace be with you
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in and see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum